Germany's foreign minister Angelina bear
book has backed calls to investigate
potential human rights violations
committed by Russia in Ukraine she was
speaking via video link to the UN Human
Rights Council in Geneva we urgently
need a commission of inquiry on Ukraine
to investigate all violations of human
rights that have been committed by
Russia since its military aggression
we must stand strong on accountability
meanwhile Germany has announced that
it's sending more weapons to Ukraine a
government Source says Berlin has agreed
to provide 2700 anti-aircraft missiles
the weapons are Soviet designs trailer
missiles from the stocks of the former
East German Armed Forces Germany had
already committed to delivering a
thousand anti-tank weapons and 500
surface-to-air missiles Berlin recently
reversed a long-standing policy of not
exporting weapons to conflict zones
let's get some background on this from
our chief political editor uh
these weapons are said to be of Soviet
production from the former East German
uh Army uh that's an irony of History
isn't it
I think we're in the process of actually
writing a new chapter in history
um these are Soviet made yes they were
delivered to the former East Germany
these are weapons that were also used in
Russia's conflict with Afghanistan back
then in the days so they're very old but
they are functioning hardware and that
is scarce currently in the German Army
and after initially
um we heard the defense minister Lamprey
saying look we have to look what we even
have what we can give out well this now
is part of a continuing list because we
do expect there to be more that can be
given to Ukraine always stressing that
there's no direct Handover Germany is
not delivering these weapons physically
does that make a difference for Russia
how is Russia viewing this it's NATO
weapons being used against them I'm sure
they're going to have something to say
about it well these are specifically not
weapons that are earmarked within NATO
contingencies and this actually is a key
point we had the Deputy foreign minister
of Russia yesterday stressing that
there's an increasing likelihood of
misunderstandings of a direct contact
between NATO and Russia which fits into
a Russian Narrative of actually NATO
being an active threat towards Russia
which NATO denies it's it's a defense
mechanism and clearly all NATO countries
that are sending weapons are at pains to
stress and to ensure that there is no
direct contact because that's what
everybody wants to avoid and that there
would be a direct confrontation with
Russia which could and you know I'm
surprised I'm even saying this but it
that is World War III scenario if that
was to happen so these are the stakes
that are on the table at the moment
terrible Stakes um the German government
recently uh set up a special budget of
100 I think 100 billion uh Euros to ramp
up defense to modernize the German Army
the bundes there and the the fierce
debate has now flared up in German
politics about that um can you bring us
up to speed it's an internal debate I
mean what we saw happening over the
weekend is the chancellor pretty much
acting alone uh turning around German
defense and foreign policy of the past
decades and now effectively troubling
the German defense budget overnight
which is quite something I was with him
as he traveled to Israel yesterday there
that was received positively Israel has
now offered a new strategic dialogue it
so far only has with Britain and the us
and it shows that there's a new
understanding of what strategic role
Germany will have also in the future and
that it has to be able to defend itself
because it's simply not able to do that
and this also fits in with the signals
we're getting from the French President
Emmanuel Macau who's now stressing
self-sufficiency is something that's
needed in the future and an own
strategic Outlook these are words we've
heard before but they're now being
backed up by money and it looks like
infrastructure and Hardware in the very
near future as well I think the money is
the important sign it always shows when
people are serious
DW's Chief political editor Michael
there for us thank you
and here are some more headlines related
to this war Russia's foreign minister
Sergey lavrov says his country will push
on with its mission to quote
demilitarize Ukraine and stop it joining
NATO
speaking on Russian television on
Thursday lavrov accused Western
countries of preparing for a war against
Russia and raising the prospect of
nuclear weapons
please in Moscow have apparently
detained a group of children for laying
flowers at the Ukraine Embassy that's
according to a social media user some
were as young as seven people were also
arrested in Saint Petersburg a
monitoring group says more than 8 000
anti-war protesters have now been
detained in the past week in Russia
the international paralympic committee
has banned Russian and Belarusian
athletes from competing at the
Paralympics that reverses a previous
decision just the day before the games
begin in Beijing on Tuesday the IPC had
said athletes from the two countries
could take part as neutrals
German karmaker Volkswagen says it will
stop exports to Russia and hold
producing Vehicles there it joins
several other car companies now
boycotting Russia over Ukraine some of
the world's biggest technology companies
clothing brands and Industrial Giants
have now cut all ties with Russia while
various shipping companies have stopped
deliveries